what's going on y'all this is Lady
London and y'all can check me out on a
bootleg Kev podcast right now hey you're
about to watch the new interview brought
to you by Blue get a month supply of
blue Chu for free fellas that's right
blu.com promo code bootleg right now get
a month supply for free helping you with
that erectile dysfunction with the same
active ingredient as Viagra and seis but
you don't got to go to the doctor it's
all online and it's delivered right to
your front door that's how we doing
things let's get into the
interview
yo boot Lake head podcast special guest
in here lady London yes how are you how
you doing I'm good TI it I'm good how
are you uh good your new album has been
out for a couple of weeks now how's it
feel it feels good I think we're
approaching our second week right now so
are you feeling like you know like I
feel like when the albums drop it's like
the work just begins you got to do all
the running around and yeah it's a lot
this is actually like New York Press was
crazy Atlanta press was kind of crazy
but you know La La's kind of more subtle
more chill yeah yeah uh for people who
don't know you're from okay you rep
Jersey but you you grew up in New York
give me the bre give me a little bit of
both yeah ex so um Early Childhood in
New York and then I moved to Jersey and
the high school there so so you rep
Jersey yeah what part East orang okay
I've only been I went to uh what part of
Jersey do we go to Jersey City yeah not
too far we were in uh what's the name of
that rapper that we shot with oh uh he
put honey he put a honey pack in his
honey bun hold on now
he just got he just got out of prison
[__] I forget yes oh yeah yeah Jersey
Jersey City we went to like his corner
store and um he did the most wild [__]
he took like the mail enhancer honey
pack yeah and he put it in his in his
food Ali Wilding that's crazy shout out
to Jersey though man yeah there was the
honey bun and the Honey pack combo who
would have thought that was crazy um so
your new album's called Soul yeah what's
the acronym stand for signs of universal
love okay yeah I like that yeah it's
it's a vibe it's all about zodiac signs
so it's like you believe in zodiac signs
huh I believe that they govern your
temperament I don't swear by them I
always you know I didn't really I'm an a
I I almost call myself an aqu that's an
outcast album I am an aquarius got it
but I don't know what that means yeah I
mean you can be often detached you can
be kind of aloof I feel like um it's
many qualities of an aquarius but of
course it all has to do with your other
placements too your moon sign your
rising sign so that's all important too
I'm curious will you like let's say if
there's somebody in your life or let's
say in your past have you not
entertained U somebody because of their
sign absolutely 100% so you believe for
real I believe that it controls certain
elements of you and it's no it's like
that can't be no coincidence that all
y'all act like that like n so if you go
on like like let's say have you ever
gone on a date with somebody found out
their zodiac sign and been like oh this
would be the last date yep wow I didn't
know people like that well it's nice to
meet somebody like that cuz I always
thought that that was like a myth no I
mean I wouldn't say my last dat but I
would be like I'm cautious you're
cautious yeah I'd be like cuz like if
everything lines up that's good but then
they but they were born in the wrong
month it's like damn I'm telling you
something coming every time every time
so what is your zodiac son I'm a cancer
what's what I don't know what that means
we're the mother of the zodiac I'm very
nurturing very uh sensitive hyper
sensitive and super moody which uh sign
are you not Kosher with uh Libras Libras
yeah Libras are psychopaths interesting
characters for sure I think great
friendships though like I have good
friendships my uh my son's mom is a
Libra and uh both of my sons are Libras
and uh oh wow yeah wow that's a heavy
household the it's
toxic a toxic sign yeah is that accurate
me saying that out Libras are a little
toxic toxic manipulative victimizing
Jesus but also Super Creative mhm um
very very good at what they do they do
something they do at the best you know
okay I say that about them for sure
shout out to the uh Libras out there so
if you if so someone's born in October
they're just done in your or late
September I have I don't have no pics
they're toasted either way wow shout out
to you um what I didn't know is so you
actually so you went to HBC you went to
Howard and graduated of course and then
you ended up coming to USC and getting a
degree here yeah was it a masters yeah
uh you're really smart uh somebody say
that yeah I'm a nerd so how many years
of college did you do is that like six I
did six well I did I did five uh I
finished my masters in a year but it was
a two-year program so yeah what was your
Masters by the way life Flex she's like
I finished my masters in a year it was a
two program I didn't want pay for the
other year I didn't want to pay for the
other year um but I did um Global
medicine Global medicine yeah so what
does that mean um it basically focuses
more so uh in like the administrative
side of things um so you can like work
for the UN or work for the wh show or so
you could like be F fuch fouche's
assistant essentially yeah right but not
that delusional but yeah yeah shout out
to that
guy uh yo it's crazy like I wonder like
with your with your background like how
did you feel about like just the whole
vaccine and all that now that we're on
the other side of it yeah and it seems
like you know we kind of got like we
kind of got Bamboozled a little cuz I
got the jab but I feel like I I feel
like I If I Had have known everything I
know now I would have totally have just
been like if I get it it's probably
better if I just get it naturally yeah I
mean I knew then just from my back
they didn't know the difference between
public health and Public Safety and I
think they were confusing the two um but
for me I I never got I never got
vaccinated because CU you're young and
healthy well no I there's you know
comorbidities that exist in in anything
but I do think that for me I was like
there's a certain thing as her immunity
after a certain point in time everybody
has to get it it's it's inevitably going
to get you and if you have something
that's going to Def defeat you like if
you have a cancer or HIV or something
like that are you higher at risk to be
you know more sick B thing yes but
that's life this is the common flu yeah
and then the other thing yeah there's so
much we can get into with that being
said I did get the I got the first jab I
didn't get the booster they couldn't
boost me okay by then I was by the time
I got the the the booster came around I
was like I don't know bro did you ever
have Co I had it [__] four times yeah
so see but you know it only it never was
bad for me though me neither like I had
it and well the first time I had it I
only knew cuz I couldn't smell okay and
so I remember my wife was cooking and my
wife can cook she's Mexican you know she
could cook oh yeah so it should have
been smelling like I was like sitting on
the couch I was playing video games or
something and I was just like oh you're
cooking and then I was like oh [__] they
got me so I walked outside to my patio
and we have like a little pad of grass
and my dog's poop on and I got on my
knees and I sniffed a turd I swear to
God I didn't put my nose to it but I
didn't smell the turd and I was like
[__] I was like f finally happened but
again I also was like running around
going to Studio sessions like I was like
you outside for sure yeah I mean for
like the first month I was inside
enjoying it yeah relaxing catching up on
some Tiger King you know I didn't get it
for two years I was I was one of them
people that wore masks everywhere didn't
go out didn't like I was I knew the the
risk of I have asthma so I was like okay
let me just be careful you being careful
but yeah I got it after 2 years and I
was like expecting a day to come like oh
my God I'm cuz my breathing is
compromised so I'm in a hotel like
quarantining like what day is it going
to be the worst day and it never came
even went it was totally fine I only had
a fever for one day and then I just
waited out the rest of it so you um
you've helped I know you've done some
acting but you've also helped write on
some TV shows yeah TV shows and some
film yeah so like helping with the
script and the lines and stuff no no no
I was more of a soundtrack okay on the
soundtrack side okay like what what what
shows I did Queens ABC um so we I wrote
for um basically the cast with Eve
Brandy um a Peppe and a to nton um so it
was really dope to do that I did um some
work on partners and Ryme with uh MC
light um I did the s l had a debut film
called on the come up um in I was in it
and I wrote the soundtrack for it so
shout out to saai I met her once in
Tampa Florida randomly I was backstage
at the it was when Chris Brown had his
tour with the Amigos and French Montana
and it was when French and sa were
dating and it was out in the world but
then I saw it mhm in Florida I was like
oh this is crazy she just walked in the
dressing room and I was just like oh
[__] we're in Tampa and S Len is here
this is incredible yeah she's incredibly
talented She's So Dope um but yeah I
didn't even audition for mine she was
like I think you could play this
character where you are so um I ended up
being that was my first time acting
debut um is that something that you're
you you got the bug for yeah I want to
do I want to do more of it for sure hey
what up y'all you already know my bookie
man we just made so much money this past
weekend if you did not get in on that
crazy deal that we had it's all good man
you can still get down with that free
deposit bonus up to $200 all right right
now if you go to mybookie.ag we're
gambling on NBA we're gambling on
football I've been murdering the NFL
murdering it I do these four team super
teasers you get plus 13 on NFL games
listen if you can't hit a plus 13 teaser
I don't know what to tell you but I will
tell you this when you go to mybookie.ag
you sign up with a new account you're
going to get that first depit bonus
using the promo code bootleg You' got to
use that promo code bootleg mybookie.ag
promo code bootleg they're going to give
you free money to gamble with that's
right it's so easy what are we talking
about man I man I've been running it up
on my bogie for almost 10 years you know
what I'm saying they reached out to me
and they were like we'd love to sponsor
your podcast I say check my accountant
ID
buddy you already been taking a lot of
my money it's time we get some of that
back but I've been on a roll with my
bookie man so go to mybookie.ag they got
the casino live Blackjack roulette
whatever you're into craps they got the
uh slots but most importantly we talking
about this sports book you could also
cash out early now what let's say you
hit three out of four of the legs on
your parlay cash that [__] out take
your money and go go back to your bed
and go to sleep you know what I'm saying
my
bookie.ag promo code bootleg get that
deposit bonus right now wherever you're
at we all good with my bookie also want
to give a shout out to our folks at
Imperial right now salute to Imperial
extractions if y'all don't know Imperial
extractions they're OG's in this man
they got 16 years of uh experience when
it comes to this West Coast cannabis
scene all right Imperial
extraction look this what they
do Straight premium luxury products if
you're a smoker if you're a toker toker
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into they got it and right now we all
love free weed I know I love free weed
who doesn't love free weed you can get a
free 2 gr
thca Diamond infused pre-roll premium
cannabis uh in it of course if y'all
ain't heard 16 years experience uh and
now Imperial extraction they're throwing
their hat into the hemp game that means
that this can get delivered to you
wherever you are wherever you're at
legally it's getting delivered to your
door la king Kush cereal milk we got
flavors for days we got flavors for days
white Berry runts come on man this is
the most important thing go to Imperial
extraction. comom use the promo code
bootleg right now they're going to send
you one of these straight to your door
for free with your order who doesn't
love free weed we're talking about a 2 G
premium luxury pre-roll look at these
glass tips come on man this ain't that
[__] this that real [__] right here
you bust one of these bad Bo Boys open
there diamonds in here bro you know what
I'm saying I'm just letting you know all
right if you want some free weed
Imperial extraction. comom Imperial
extraction. promo code bootleg get you a
free pre-roll sent to your crib right
the [__] now let's get back to the
interview you know acting you get
there's no you don't have to
recoup so I hear as long as I don't play
myself yeah as long as you don't play
it's crazy too cuz like uh for you like
I feel like we're in like a Rena SS of
like it used to be a thing where you
would describe an artist as like a
female rapper M but female rappers are
running rap yeah so it's just like
rappers yeah yeah like it's like the
best like you know if you could like
rewind like 2018 2017 it'd be like oh
there's this new female Ro how many
female rappers can pop at the same time
it was that narrative cuz it was like
just Nikki for so long but now it's like
I just wish the dudes would care about
making real records like the women are
these days I think we we had our time
like we we deserve this time now it's
been so many years um since all woman
Dynamic was dominating that's probably
like well back in the day it was like
the you had like the brat Little Kim
foxy Eve like a lot of people doing
their thing at the same time I feel like
now though it's like way crazier yeah it
is and there's so many like spectrums
like you could get rap city is one of
the greatest period shout to rap city
and then you got like sexy red who you
can you know for sure I love the
dichotomy between all of them that's I
think it's dope Have you listened to
Andre 3000
I can't wait to listen to it I haven't
sat down yet but like that Andre
somebody I'm an Enthusiast of like I
just feel like whatever he drops I want
toast album right there it's my fa
that's like my third favorite album of
all time I love that I love Outcast but
no I I'm not going to lie I saw I saw
the press release and I was just so [__]
I was like yes yeah and then I read and
it was like there'll be no rapping it's
just the flute I said okay well at least
I'll have some music to trip on shrooms
too
eat some shrooms get high let Andre play
the flute in the background no and I
like his self- awareness in it too I
feel like evolution is so important for
artists to like understand what what
what a lane of Life they're in at the
moment yeah like did you saw what he
said yeah he was like I don't have
nothing to rap about so you want me to
rap about getting a colonoscopy and I
was like sure I literally listen to you
rap about anything yeah yeah
colonoscopies uh you know IRAs whatever
you want to wrap about but we're going
to get the flute sounds the flute I'm
excited about that uh on this new album
you got a lot of dope features amaretta
who I think is really dope and slept on
yeah she's incredible um who who's first
of all what's your favorite song on the
album and for you what was like the
feature that meant the most to get done
for this one H that's a good question um
my favorite song changes often but right
now it's safety net um it's the track of
Brook Valentine number 10 um and it's
just very like wait Brook Valentine is
that girl fight yeah girl fight yeah oh
wait she's married to my boy yeah yeah
so she's on a Virgo record because she's
married to a Virgo which is my brother
Marcus like love him your brother my bro
like my bro he's a great guy yeah he's
he's incredible he just hit me like a
month ago for real and told me hey my
wife do you want to book her at cuz I
have a club in Scott still and I was
like you're married to Brooke Valentine
yes yeah I just yeah shout out to Brook
Valentine girlfriend yeah okay shout out
to Marcus great guy great family yeah I
love like his like he just be giving
game away you know what I'm saying free
game yeah for sure I love it um but yeah
that's like one of my favorite on the
project and then my favorite person I
have worked with throughout it
um she I was happy to uh damn everybody
I really enjoy everybody was there like
a studio like what like were cuz these
days you might get a song sent to you
were you able to like get I sat down
with everybody I flew into each person's
like Hometown or whatever and I made an
environment I would say I I did safety
net yeah yeah and act like you know all
in one session at west lake and
everybody was there everybody who was
featuring on it came came into the
studio and we did it together was that
the funnest session it was the most uh
productive yeah creative yeah it was
just it was just really fun like to
watch everybody's like ideas ping off
each other and stuff like that was
really dope what is your uh pen game
like are you writing everything are you
yeah are you punching in like how do you
no I'm I'm one take lady like I'm
literally I don't punch often so you'll
have you'll have your [__] like look I'm
I ready I'm already ready yeah or like
I'll I'll write in there if I'm like cuz
like safety that for example I wrote the
whole so
like I sat down and I can't sing so I'm
like girl like you know this what we
doing this what we doing we got do and
so um yeah she just man everybody did
their part on that you know how much
writing do you do for other people uh
not as much anymore I I kind of got my
start in songwriting at first so I used
to you know obviously be in writing
sessions and whatever whatever but now
that's a It's a Grind people don't know
man oh my cuz you might be in a session
and feel like we got one and then it
doesn't make the album yeah that happens
all the time and the song's just like
in I don't know and you don't know whose
hands will end up in like that's the
crazy part is knowing like you wrote it
for this person and then this person has
it now or you know or it comes out 5
years later and you're like yeah like
when you're a producer and a songwriter
it is a it is a It's a Grind man cuz cuz
those Studio sessions can be 8 10 12
hours and then you don't even know if
it's if you even got anything out of it
like hey what up y'all we got to stop
the interview tell you about our good
Folks at King pom that's right let me
tell you about King pom man it's all we
smoking over here what I love about King
pom turpine infused flavor in each one
of these These are the margarita now
this is kind of the wave I've been on
recently these Margarita ones are
[__] fire no tobacco no nicotine
straight raw organic fresh leaves um and
what's dope is they got the tip you
squeeze the tip you hit one of these
boys and you just get hit with that
flavor man you get hit with that flavor
no matter how big or small the Palm is
is you know what I'm saying this is
what's dope too uh King pal if y'all
don't know man they're one of the
leading Brands when it comes to this
real like organic smoke light that's why
I like them I like to smoke clean
nothing smokes cleaner than a King Palm
so if you're in your hood you're in your
neighborhood you're in your
[__] City your area wherever
you're at go to your local liquor store
they're going to have King poms all
right so pick them up there you could
also go to 7-Eleven or this is what I
suggest you do right now come on
shout out to the king poms man go to the
website King pom.com you go to King
pom.com you use the promo code bootleg
this is what we're doing 50% off
whatever you order they got so much at
King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones 50% %
off all the smoking accessories all the
leaves you need all the flavors 50% off
King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
our our listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party odd
Soxs baby the holidays are here now is
the time to go to oddsocks official.com
and use that promo code bootleg all
right use it right now and guess what
you're going to get 20% off at checkout
now the dope thing about odds sock they
got all the crazy licenses they just
locked down Coca-Cola recently yeah look
at those they just locked down Hasbro so
they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got WWE they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the drawers they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need oddsock official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Sox to your loved
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it odd Sox official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview so what who who's who's some
people you've written for rather not
speak on it can we check the credits
probably probably yeah yeah as a writer
is there any advice you would give
because I see a lot of uh more dialogue
about how there's some like you know
some of the pub deals in the past have
been kind of predatory I just saw hit
point you know last year has kind of
talked about his OG Pub deal but would
there be any advice you'd give in terms
of the pub game like I would say just um
ask for your points I would say that
that would really be it um a lot of
people publishing is so weird nowadays
with with everything they try to give
you like the least percentage and you
done did most of the and then they they
got like these minimum delivery
requirements which are like I I think
it's like it might look like oh yeah I
only got to do 10 records right but no
that's 10 that's that's that's a th000
points right so it's like if you if you
do the most like you said you do the
most work on a record you might think
well [__] I should get 25 30 no you
might get 10 five you might get eight
yeah that's what I'm saying you might
get like you got to understand like you
got to get so many placements to hit 10
compositions for sure yeah so it's it's
a wicked game I say just make sure you
have great lawyers for real for
sure obviously uh you're kind of by
Coastal at this point when you were
growing up though being um uh in the
east coast who were your main es to like
your style would you say um definitely
Jay-Z jiss um Big L Lauren Hill CH to
Big L um yeah man uh Lauren Hill Missy
um foxy Kim uh I would say those were
like the main people I really modeled my
career behind as far as musically I love
big L yeah me too one of the greats
honestly his I feel so um relatable to
him cuz I feel like my catalog because I
this is my first project in the
marketplace and I'm like wow I feel like
I can walk away now and be like I feel
like that was a really good that was a
really good thing technically Big L
while he was alive I only put out one
album lifestyles of the PO and dangerous
the big picture came out after he passed
so yeah but even if you go back to like
his freestyles and you know like he's
competing at the highest level y that
freestyle where he watched oh listen
shout out to Jay-Z Jay-Z held his home
but 97 Hope was CRA 96 oh my God 96
freestyle big [__] SP spazzed the
[__] out yeah he went crazy so ahead of
his time his parents yeah oh my God
that's crazy yeah shout out to Big L I
always cuz there's all those rumors that
like he was talking to Jay-Z or Dame
about signing to Rockefeller before he
passed and I'm like yo if he would have
signed a
Rockefeller you never like he'd be one
of them ones yeah yeah I mean yeah life
cut short yeah shout out to him and have
you ever listen to any of the Children
of the Corn stuff um not really I heard
of it but no I had really got into it
it's dope that Ma and cameon now do a
show together yes I love that did you
see I that so much mace just got Cameron
a massage from Joe Smith's wife live on
the show I see that mace is funny though
he's a funny person in hilarious
hilarious um all right so look this
album is out right now everyone go check
it out Soul uh and uh this is your first
body of work yeah are you already
working on something new yeah so
technically this is just a project this
is actually not an album this is kind of
like okay so this is just a first yeah
first body for first project
um they're not letting me call it an EP
cuz it's like long so I've been say
pretty long EP yeah it's a pretty long
EP basically um but yeah I'm working I'm
I'm beginning to work on my first album
now and who knows how long that's going
to take cuz the album for me is like
very serious yeah you got I mean look
that debut album's got to be yeah it's
got to be up there and you know that
cloth that you listen to you grew up
listening to that first album I know I
know um is there any uh tour stuff
coming hopefully um top of spring top of
spring yeah next year Well I appre
appreciate you pulling up thank you for
having me I appreciate it lady London
you already know boom fire yo we're
wrapping up an interview man of course
we want to shout out to our family at
harden baby Harden Las Vegas celebrating
their seventh birthday this month so
happy birthday to harden uh want to give
a shout out to the whole family over
there when you're in Las Vegas you got
to pull up the Hardy and tell them that
the bootleg head podcast sends you
they're going to take care of you it is
the craziest selection of Premium
cannabis in the country all Under One
Roof you walk in and it's just a Vibe
beautiful butt tenders amazing smoke
just the illst merch you know what I'm
saying and it's right in Los Vegas right
in s City so you land in Vegas you about
to go gamble with your boys you get in
that cab you say take me to harden
they're going to know exactly where to
take you all right shout out to harden
go follow him Hardin Las Vegas or go to
the website Hardin vegas.com